こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
今日は13時間寝てました
13時間も寝る...
13時間も寝るとさすがにちょっとぼーっとしますね
ちょ..録画したかも忘れちゃったよ...今..
今まだちょっとぼーっとしますけど
ちょっとやってみたいことがあるのでやりまーす
スタジアム！
シューター！！
そして本体！！！
こちら...ベイブレードでございます
昔ちょっとやってみたんですけど
最近ベイブレード
アニメが始まりまして...
またね...熱くなってきております
趣味としてちょっとベイブレードをね始めようと
ほんとに思ってまして
アニメの主人公が使っているこちらのベイブレード
といいます
ハアァ！！
僕は今回何をしようかといいますと
この最新のベイブレードと
昔流行ってた普通のベイブレードがあります
これ分かる人いるかなぁ...？
これとか知ってますか？
ドラグーンV2
ガイアドラグーン
ドライガーファングです
マジで懐かしい
ウルボーグ
というわけでこちらの初代ベイブレード
まさきからﾊﾟｸ..
貸してもらいました
昔の初代のベイブレードでございます
このころのベイブレードはもうね
販売されたらすぐ売り切れで
手に入れるのが難しかったんですけど...
あっ フラッシュレオパルドだ...
昔のベイブレードですね
僕のイメージだと
めちゃくちゃ強いんですよ
フラッシュレオパルドは強いんすよね
という感じでですね
昔のベイブレードは強かった
そこで僕は思ったよ！
ベイブレードバーストのヴィクトリーヴァルキリー
こいつと
この初代のベイブレードを戦わせたら
どっちが強いか？
いやもう純粋な疑問ですよ
今の技術が進歩してたら
こっちの方が強いかもしんないし
ひょっとしたら昔の方が
強いんじゃねぇかなって思ってさ
ドラグーンとかめちゃくちゃ強いわけよ
というわけで今回は
昔のベイブレードと今のベイブレード
どっちが強いかちょっと検証してみようとおもいます
これでね 今のねバーストの方が強かったら
めっちゃやる気が出る
これでですよ
昔のベイブレードの方が強かったら
....
うん...
というわけで早速戦わせてみましょう
一回戦の相手はなんかなんとも言えねえところをまず倒すか
こいつにしよう
ここらへんならまあ軽く…
あ、まって俺１人でどうやって戦うんだ
待って待って待って１人でどうやって戦うんだろう
まあ適当にやりましょう
というわけで一回戦
ドラシエル対ヴィクトリーヴァルキリー
バーストのベイブレードはぶっ壊れる可能性もあるからね
かなりねハンデを持ってるわけよ
その中でどう戦うかつったらね
３，２，１，GO…
ごめんもう一回
３．２．１、GO　SHOOT!
さあ始まったよ！
うぉ、うぉ、よっしゃああああああああ！！！！！！
はい！一回戦、ヴィクトリーヴァルキリーの勝ちでございます！
はぁぁ、はぁぁ、はぁぁ。。。
よかったぁ
現代科学は強いぜ！！
次！
ドライガーはね、持久タイプだった気がする
持久戦ということで、勝つのかどうかってとこですね。
行きます！３．２．１．GO　SHOOT!
ん？
ドライガーもいない…
あらぁっ…
ドライガーリングアウトの、ヴィクトリーヴァルキリーは…
残ってます…
ヴィクトリーヴァルキリーの勝ちぃ！…
おーおーおーいいよ！見合ってる見あってる見合ってる…
見合ってる…おっ　アクション！
ぐるぐる回ってるのがドライガーです。
あれ、嫌な予感がしてきた…
いやこれは仕方ないよ…
攻撃タイプで接触できなかったら勝てないからね…
これは相性的な問題かな、と思います。
つぎぃ！
ドランザー行こうか。
ドランザーはバランスタイプなので
なかなかね、つかみどころのない戦い方をします。
GO　SHOOT!
さぁ！さぁさぁさぁ…
さあどうなるか。
あっへっえっ今、えっえっちょとちょとちょとちょっと回転してた気がします（？）
ヴィクトリーヴァルキリー勝ちぃ！
最後はこちらっ
主人公、木ノ宮タカオのベイブレードです
左回転のドラゴンワインダーでやりますから。
GO…SHOOT!
おぉっ、これはっ、これはっ、これはっ、これはわからんぞ！！
これはわからんぞ！！
はっ、勝った！！！！！！！！！！
勝った…！
やったぁぁぁぁぁぁ！！！！！！…
おぁぁあでも持久戦で持ち込まれると…
おぉぉぉっしゃぁ！！
おぉし、おし、おし。よしよしよし！
いいねぇ
いやぁ…苦しいかっ…
おっけぇぇぇぇぇ！！！
おっけーーい！
おっけ、おっけ、おっけ、おっけー！
あぁぁぁ…。駄目だ、駄目だ…
まぁまぁまぁ…
まじかっ
持久タイプだこれっ。
っっしゃあああああああ！！！！！！！
うううおっしゃぁぁい
っっっしゃあああああああああ！！！！！！！
弱点ドライガーだ。
持久系には弱いな。
わぁァァァァァっぁぁ！！！！！…